all right guys bang-bang super excited
have Nathan here thanks for doing this
man
yeah preciate having me on for sure now
you're in Austin Texas correct
yeah lockdown here in Austin all right
is uh is the virus actually keeping
people inside I'm in New York City and
it seems like on the weekends or when
it's sunny out no one no one's listening
well you know the governor just you know
open basically everything so you're
starting to see people come back out but
it is it's this weird kind of social
dynamic which is I feel healthy I feel
good I want to go outside and be social
but I have elderly neighbors and like
what if I walk by their sidewalk and
COFF and then they walk by five minutes
later and like breathe something you
know it's it's this like social
responsibility thing which is I think
keeping everyone hesitant yeah for sure
for those that don't know you let's just
start with with your background and kind
of what you did pre college so I think
once you were in college a lot of kind
of fun you know cool stuff started
happening but what was life like pre go
to pretty tech I was living in a log
cabin in Northern Virginia Loudoun
County before the political wealth move
from DC to Loudoun so Loudoun was not
exploding at this point so it's 45
minutes west of DC lived in a log cabin
in the woods right on Goose Creek and I
was you know I spent most of my summers
either building connects you know the
little you know you know connects our
Lincoln Logs Legos or chopping wood my
house was was on a wood burning kind of
fire and so that was how we heated so I
spent a lot of my summers just chopping
wood and so that was a lot of my
pre-college life got it and then
ultimately drove the decision like why I
choose to go to Virginia Tech so I
generally just liked architecture I was
building a ton of stuff I wasn't kind of
in the money-making mindset but my first
two jobs I managed the you know during
October in the States we have these
Halloween kind of fairs and there was
this big one locally where there's this
massive slide that went down a hill at
hey slide and will you go you're getting
a sack and you slide down I was the guy
at the top of slide that made sure the
kids there was ten seconds between every
time they went down to the one hit each
other was my first job at like 10 bucks
an hour
then it was soccer refereeing and so I
liked making money and saving but
ultimately I love just building and
construction and so I looked at kind of
who had the top programs in the country
Virginia Tech was ranked up there
towards the top so I applied and got in
but things quickly changed when I heard
seniors at the school because they mix
the seniors and the freshmen in
architecture there and they were gonna
buy me pomp they're looking to be gone
we're graduating we can't find jobs and
and Tech was you know battling with
Cornell the time for the number one and
number two spot in the country for
architecture and I looked at I'm
thinking why would I put myself through
five years of this madness potentially
debt and not a guaranteed good job at
the end of it and that changed my
thinking got it and so when that
thinking did change you kind of went
down this path of entrepreneurship and
it seems like both a mindset shift but
also a mindset shift that drove changes
in your actions so maybe talk a little
bit about like why the mindset shift how
did that happen was it something you
read or somebody you talked to and then
kind of what you actually put into
action coming off with that mindset
shift so freshmen and sophomore years at
Virginia Tech I picked up a part-time
job at West End girl flipping burgers
and I had the optimization between the
chicken tender fryers and the I had
there was a grill with the hamburgers
and then there was a we did these like
potato sack things with cheese on them
that under a heat lamp and I have like
the shortest path possible between all
three to get the meals out the quickest
and you know is doing all this
optimization and stuff but ultimately
like what I realize between you know my
West End job and architecture students
who couldn't get jobs I said like like I
just got takes into my own hands I never
want to be in a position where I'm like
relying on somebody else for like income
and happiness and at that time and even
today I correlate those two together
right I think there's enough correlation
there so I started selling Facebook fan
pages actually so maybe we actually
share a little bit of Brotherly DNA in
this regard
you were X Facebook as well but I was
selling when the Facebook fan pages used
to have long banners it was like 300
pixels across the top and like six
minute pixels long for fan pages I would
sell those custom graphics to like
celebrities and I would basically called
email them and say hey you don't have
an executive Facebook fan page profile
cover are you a real executive I just
made that term up but the point was it
allowed me to sell these things so I
sold you know these were each of these
were like a hundred bucks a pop and I
started selling like between 20 and 30 a
month and that started that's kind of
where my entrepreneurial bug started I
always say that there's this feeling of
one excitement but two kind of expansion
of the mind when you start to see money
come in from something you built right
like that first checker or that first
customer you're like wait a second I did
X and I received why like why don't I go
to X a bunch of time so he'd be talking
about like what like do you remember
what that first sale actually was yeah
my first sale was from a lady named
Audra who ran a fan page called women
oughta know and it was a uto she ran her
own mechanic like shop and I created her
custom fan page and I actually page 34
in the book I put the screenshot of the
invoice it was a $700 invoice you'd pay
me that was my first ever money were
like I felt like I did it myself but
then my wheels all like I think most
really good entrepreneurs are actually
very lazy so they spent a lot of time I
mean I spent a lot of time thinking
about the quickest way to do things so I
can go back to being lazy what that
really means is the quickest way to do
things so then I could fill my time with
things that I wanted to do right and so
I started thinking about what can I tell
Thais this can I hire someone on Fiverr
to do it for a hundred bucks I mark it
up to seven hundred I started thinking
about margins and and my time and things
like that but that was the first moment
a 700 ollar check from Audra love it and
and so I actually started to do this
when at what point did you say hey look
actually I want to you know write a book
about my experience was that something
you knew you always wanted to do or
right out of the gate or did you
actually kind of get further in the
process and then say now I want to write
it well mr. bone my I think it was 11th
grade English teacher would tell you
this guy Nathan watt has no idea how to
write a thesis paper much less has no
business writing a book because I got I
think maybe a C in his English class in
high school you know the book was the
book was driven because publishers were
putting their their writers on my
podcast and
I saw the book volume that I drove
because the Amazon ranked shot up when I
released the interview so they pressure
me to write it because they knew I could
sell that's a whole that was a whole
different sort of animal
but like pulling forward from the
fanpage stuff I realized the way to make
more money was to build software to
enable Audra to build her own Facebook
bandwidth to drag-and-drop platforms so
you know this world well this was the
age of involve our wildfire the true
buddy media these drag-and-drop fanpage
kind of app filters and that's the space
I played in my first SAS company heyo
comm 8gy Oh which you know we're
asymmetric capital for we grew at about
five million dollars in sales and I sold
it in 2015 to our number-one competitor
called vote ago so that's still alive
now once I sold that then I got into the
podcasting game which led to the book
got it and so as you're doing that like
why sell the business right it's growing
five million dollars in sales for most
people like a SAS company would love to
get to that point most kind of die
before they ever get there uh what was
kind of a logic or framework you used
and actually selling the business well
so what he so see the way I said it
you know we're a central capital I sold
at five million sales your natural
flowers oh this must have been growing
no no it actually wasn't growing like we
had a massive year in 2012 with about a
million and a half of sales but then
over time each year we were declining
about six to seven percent every year
and one of the biggest mistakes I made
was that that prime year 2012 when vitru
wildfire buddy meeting all these guys
exited for hundreds of millions of
dollars we got a smaller offer it's on
page 243 in the book from eye contact
for six point three million dollars and
I couldn't sell them I wanted to sell
the business I owned 60% of it so that
would put a lot of money in my bank at
21 years old the problem was I had
raised two million from VCS and not a
six point five million our exit on two
million raised was not interesting to
them so they blocked the deal from going
through and so I just kept trying to
build the business but we missed like
with any company like timing is
everything
2012 was the year of Facebook apps we
should have sold that year we declined
heyo steadily year after year after that
we passed five million in sales when you
add up all the sales over the life of
the business which was about four and a
half five years I was 19 to 24 years old
and then sold it in 2015 really add up
pop I caught a discount flash sale I
just wanted to end and move on to the
next thing is my biggest value in life
at that point was not building the
business it was the opportunity cost of
my time no kids single can be anywhere
you got to do something bigger than a
Facebook fan page builder yeah I
actually know some of the folks from
iContact it was in North Carolina right
Ryan Alice right yeah yeah okay so and
then help us understand so once you
write the book what's that process looks
like you just sit down one day drink
some coffee and bang out the whole book
or is this kind of an iterative process
that took you know months and months so
back to my point about being efficient I
was not gonna do a book unless I could
reverse-engineer a best-seller before I
even wrote a word before I even came up
with a freaking title and so I started
thinking like what what makes a
best-seller well number one this is kind
of an ego check but also the market
responds better when you're publishing a
book by a major author major publisher
right right so I wanted like Random
House or like one of these number one
folks I said well how do I get them to
say yes so I got myself with an agent
named Jim Levine he's really the best I
mean he published radios book principles
he published you know he's it works with
Satya Nadella at Microsoft on refresh he
does all the big books so there buddy
get him as an agent and what I did to
land him as an agent cuz he's not he
barely takes meetings is i pre-sold I
actually had invoices for copies of the
book and people you might go oh wait
what was the book titled the book is
about what I did is I messaged all the
CEOs I had on my podcast so it had about
four hundred at the time I ping them on
said hey I'm writing a book it's gonna
be a massive bestseller I'll put a page
in there about you and your metrics and
a case study about your company if you
agree to sign this invoice to buy a
hundred copies at fifteen bucks apiece
so the $1500 invoice sign and I had a
stack of these so I basically had like
thirty thousand dollars in pre-sales I
took those pre-sales to my agent and he
said oh my god I've never had an author
come to me with sign invoice on a book
that
have a title yet she then took those two
about seven authors and publishers and
those publishers of the 17 emailed three
one and in-person meetings in New York
when the board meetings had the
conversation and got a got a book deal
with Random House and the trick with
that negotiation was you want the
publisher to give you in advance that's
much larger than the you know the
average advance today is probably three
or four grand you want to get something
between like two hundred and eight
hundred thousand dollars because then
the publisher can't ignore you if your
book flops
it's a massive write down for them they
can ignore you if it's only a five
thousand dollar advance you can fail so
we got a big advance it was larger or
just say larger than hundred fifty grand
and that made the publisher push for all
the press and PR that I got when the
book launch and that that's gonna how I
start to reverse-engineer a best-seller
got it and what do you think is like the
biggest takeaway so those that haven't
read the book like if they go read it
what do they walk away with from like
yeah I mean the book is really look I'm
like the Amazon reviews I think really
are actually pretty accurate the most
common comment I get is this feels like
an updated 4-hour workweek which is look
it's a big compliment I'm a big fan of
Tim I'm a big fan of everything he's
doing and 4-hour workweek was massive in
my childhood in terms of reading and
growing up along with Rich Dad Poor Dad
but like the big takeaways they're just
a ton of screenshots in the book of like
how I did things like launch my podcasts
on patreon and got a thousand people
paying ten bucks a month you know the
updated version of that would be like
how you grew your sub stack right or
there's all these kinds of tools so like
you know how I launched and how I wrote
software without having to know code
using a site called top towel I
basically put like all these like growth
hacks and email scripts of how I sold my
company and all this stuff in the book
however the podcast so you know large
sponsorship deals I put it all in the
book and so people can like take out
only two or three pages and get a lot of
value without reading the whole thing
that's really the big takeaways again
how to make money without starting with
a lot of capital for sure and the book
is called how to be a capitalist without
any capital which is a pretty catchy
you know title there and obviously it
kind of leads this idea of I don't think
you wrote the book as a personal finance
or finance education book but that's
really to some degree what
showing people right is how to use their
time which is an asset how to use a lack
of capital which some would look as an
obstacle to your advantage and to build
a sustainable business that can drive
you know income in multiple streams of
income right that's right I mean the
book for me was really an exercise and
documenting what I had done between the
ages of like 15 and 25 right how I how I
you know college how I launched company
I raised capital how I used the capital
I grew sell how I sold but but
ultimately for me I don't know if you
played sports in college or guys I don't
know if you guys let's say you played
sports in college you guys on YouTube
and iTunes but I'm extremely competitive
so like all my friends you know they
wrote a best-selling book and this is
totally the wrong reason to write a book
but I was like I wonder if I can write a
book I wonder if I could do this I'm
like well how do I get leverage and so
the way I got leverage is every time I
had a podcast guest on my podcast that
had a book I would take a screenshot of
their Amazon rank before I released the
episode and a screenshot of the Amazon
rank right the day it released and I'd
email and said hey released your episode
love to see that it's selling books your
Amazon ranked increased by like thirty
thousand spots right and then the base
sent that to their publishers and their
publisher that oh my gosh this guy
Nathan can sell and that's how I that's
how I kept levered a lot of people go
into book publishing as they try and
like bag an agent to represent them on
their book deal I wanted to again have
the leverage first get to distribution
build a distribution channel first and
then pump the product through it and I
think that's kind of where the future of
media is going right or early snow night
in the future I mean it's basically
happening now where we used to see
companies build products and then go try
to find their customers or find the
distribution and they would test a bunch
of stuff on the distribution side after
the product was built now what you're
seeing actually is the reverse where
people go good at the distribution they
build out big audiences and then they
figure out what product I want to sell
this audience or the kind of this these
eyeballs right maybe talk a little bit
about how you think about that that
shift and how that's changed what you're
doing on a day to day basis the number
one thing I spent time on at heyo was
trying to convince affiliates that are
30% cut we would give them is worth them
like emailing their list about us and I
hated it
because I was doing it over and over and
over
but what these affiliates have done is
they built great distribution channels
in the front of a blog you know from an
email newsletter whatever YouTube
Twitter you name it and say knew what
the what's much smarter to build for my
next thing this was in 2015 is dominate
like pick a space that you love right
and then figure out a build a dominant
distribution channel in that space and
then based off you know reviews on
iTunes or feedback you're getting your
email replies you'll you'll fall most
fall into products you can sell to that
space that add them value but what's way
more viable than any product in my
opinion again is the distribution
channel it's the reason like we've
launched I can't there's not one in
distance here but we've launched like a
magazine for my focus now is SAS
software entrepreneurs launched a
magazine if the book we have the podcast
and all these things allow me to now
sell my main thing which is debt into
SAS companies but the distribution has
to come first I think yeah so talk about
that a little bit more right is as you
started to build the distribution you
started with the podcast first yet the
book and then maybe walk us through just
kind of sequentially what you did and
why you made each one of those decisions
was it something that you learned from
kind of the past work you were doing or
was it somebody came to you like help us
understand kind of what drove each one
of those decisions so the pot that I
started the podcast I sell the company
in 2015 in August of 2015 I launched a
podcast biggest question you first off
like besides like the basic stuff like
what microphone you use right by the way
I have like a home studio that cost me
about 30 bucks so these it's quick to
put together the second thing is so how
do you start getting big guests on the
show and so what I start because I had
no show so what I did is I emailed about
a hundred people I wanted on the show
and basically said hey I'd love to do an
episode with you we will have a million
downloads buddy bye bye winter basically
we're launching August and so what they
heard was we have a million downloads
but I said we will I have emails we will
have a million doubt that confidence
allowed me to get about 10 verse and
those interviews actually done so I had
50 pre-recorded before I launched the
show and then I used a little bit of
kind of social dynamic I guess you'd
call it to get these people to market
the show so what I said is hey guys I'm
picking ten of these to go live on with
on launch day
it'll be the 10 of you that first agreed
to email your lists about your episode
and so I basically had 10 people sending
out emails at about 3 million emails
going out on day 1 for the podcast which
just shot us way up number 1 of the
ranking you take that screen shot to get
new guests and so I just kind of I call
it elephant bumping you're just
connecting and you're using other
people's audiences and delivering value
than to your audience and so that
bumping got us to more than a million
downloads by that winter today the show
has more than 10 million and and I look
at you know I look at the podcast almost
probably I think maybe how Native
Americans looked at corn right it's a
it's a thing to trade
it's like bartering it's like you know I
have each week seven inventories of corn
one interview a day and you can like
trade this for all kinds of things
whether it's a keynote at the person's
event that you're interviewing or or
email Boston there I mean there's so
many things you can trade for but I use
it to trade and then that you know built
into the book the book then built into
the magazine which we now you know we
launched the magazine it now ships
monthly to about 10,000 CEOs and they
all pay for its twenty nine bucks an
issue so maybe the most expensive
magazine out there these days and then
from that I listen to what entrepreneurs
wanted and a lot of them said Nathan we
don't want to get diluted from these
seas we really like art we have a great
business with health unit economics why
can't we get debt debt basically cheap
debt it says it oh my gosh that's why I
should start doing I should start
loaning money to SAS companies can keep
their companies as they scale and that's
what I'm doing today I think we'll
deploy probably anywhere between 15 and
20 million in capital and the SAS coming
over the next 12 months as debt got it
and so I got us about the magazine right
that's not exactly the thing that most
people would say hey let's go start a
magazine given pretty much every
magazine is either struggling or
shutting down how did that come together
so the way this came together is I so
when I did the book deal Random House
published on a forum that they had
signed me up to do the book deal this
forum is also the forum
a lot of TV execs watch because they'll
immediately license the right to the
book if they like the title and
personality and so I got you just you
guys wonder how people get reality shows
this is how it happens I got blasted
with about 30 emails from production
companies the day Random House announced
that they signed me to this book deal
from that I basically picked one of
these productions to work with they even
said you need to hire an agent so I had
WME UTA see a kind of battle a bit ended
up signing with CAA that signing allowed
me to do a lot of deals connect with a
lot of media personalities and one of
the things that I did this would have
been back when Meredith was buying time
fortune and money those assets from
[Music]
another name is Talia save me from The
Times The Times whatever Meredith bought
the time time basically and so those
three assets I got in the deal the back
end do remove and I saw the PLS for
fortune and money magazine and and time
and I said oh my gosh
if you build a magazine the right way it
can be massively profitable I mean
almost 80% of fortunes fortunes a bit
dumb at that time this would have been
back a year and half the goes to 2018
came from there women's event not like
all their events there there Forbes top
or fortune top women event because each
ticket was ten thousand dollars and the
minimum sponsorship was five hundred
grand I mean they were doing a lot of
millions we'll just called a lot of
millions from that so I said wow there's
a space to launch a magazine here after
I saw these you know economics and so we
launched the magazine and the economics
rush just worked right I mean I spend
$1500 a month putting the magazine
together which is really transcripts and
visualizations of my podcasts so the
Condon's already created you put the
magazine together I then pay about $3 an
issue to produce it and ship it
domestically in the US right so my
all-in cost weighted average is like
Forrest bucks we sell it for 29 and then
we upsell on the back another $29
magazine sale a raw data Excel version
of the data we put in the magazine for
founder's VC's and analysts to analyze
and
our average cart value at checkout for
the magazine is actually about $78 with
the upsell and so that's why I tested it
in one month it was profitable and I
said we got to keep building this and
that's why the map that's why I've
continued the magazine today then
obviously to get you know ten thousand
plus people to subscribe to the magazine
you're probably not calling all ten
thousand people maybe talk a little bit
about what was like the tactical thing
you did to start to really drive those
subscription numbers yeah so there's
some social numbers on the magazine come
down you know it's nothing too crazy but
it's like when you have this piece of
paper on your desk other people ask
about it right so you know Andreessen
for example you know many people they
read the magazine and it would sit on
their desk in the lobby on their
Sandhill Road office other founders when
they're waiting like come in they check
on their substance they sit down they'd
wait they pick the thing about the
coffee table read and go wow if n
driessen's reading this I should to they
would then sign up on the spot on their
phone right it's you know via the link
right it's because we put the link it
basically there's a call to action on
the cover that says to your copy of the
magazine or so you don't miss out next
month go to natal maka comm for its ouch
magazine and then boom they would sign
up so that was one strategy just word of
mouth ii was one person at a company
would grab it and then i would look them
up on linkedin using clear bit data and
see that they actually have you know a
thousand people on their company and I'd
offer to ship them a thousand a hundred
as a test they would then get the
hundred they liked it and then they want
to basically consistently order call it
40 or 50 every single month and so
that's how we kind of slowly grew that
and now what I'm doing this is kind of
how these things leveraged together is I
am basically working with airports like
right now pomp is the moment where I am
locking down all of my airport
distribution so my book placement at the
front of every airport shop my magazine
placement on every magazine rack why
because nobody else is buying airport
placement right now no one's traveling
so I'm locking all this stuff down for
the next decade right now using the book
sale through data plus the magazine sale
data the margin data to lock these
things down makes it makes a ton of
sense it also feels like
you know once you figure out one piece
of it so whether it's the podcast the
book the magazine maybe 70 80 percent of
the knowledge can be ported over to the
other content types and you've got to
figure out some tweaks here and there
but would you say that that's right like
most of it is the same thing around
making sure it's proper unit economics
and the distribution it's just a
different content type you're pushing
yeah so again the hard part for most
content creators is not creating the
content they love creating the content
the hard part is finding a content
creator that also knows how to market
and not only market but systematize we
were talking about this before the show
what I like to do is I only record two
days a month usually but our there
fifteen minute episodes with a five
minute break so it's 20 minutes total
for one episode to record I'll do three
an hour and I'll record from 9:00 a.m.
to 6:00 p.m. so we'll not got like 25
episodes in a day and my thinking is
always if I only work that one day right
a month how could just that audio data
and the video with my guests create a
bunch of other assets and so there's a
whole system where that one audio and
video file then gets transcribed then
goes through a designer to go into the
magazine it also by the way gets chopped
up and I'll put on YouTube it also gets
chopped up and a segment gets put on the
previous episode on iTunes to foreshadow
it's a drive you know additional like
addictive habits from listeners it also
goes into an Amazon echo feed that's put
up by search it goes into the email it
goes to get lock accom via thing called
a spectrograph or audio data is put into
an Excel format so like that one day I
now have so much leverage on that one
day that I think is the opportunity for
most content creators today is with the
same time input how can you generate 20x
the returns 20x the audience with that
same time input from you recording a
two-hour episode or me recording a 20
minute episode for sure and let's talk a
little bit about you have to SAS
database and it's all over kind of your
Twitter bio and stuff and there's
probably passive traffic that comes
through that but maybe talk just like
what was the genesis of the idea for
creating actual database and how do you
think about that fitting into all of the
other content
and really educational materials that
you're creating well so the the the
current podcast today didn't start out
that way so going back together I
launched in 2015 the first question you
always have is what do you name your
podcast and for me I'm a results kind of
guy so I just looked on Google Trends
and I said what's the number one most
searched term for podcasts and the
answer was people just search the top
podcast I'm like well heck I'll just
name my podcast the top podcast it's
like I get so much organic traffic just
because I named it the number one search
term and so now I own that term so your
allow figures ago my god this is like so
stupid it's like simple stupid but that
was it and so what I learned was the
episode that started doing the best were
not the ones with like an Instagram
influencer it was the ones where I was
putting on a bit of a show and what I
mean by that is I would interview a
founder and ask them questions that made
me very uncomfortable
like what equity do you still own of the
company what was your last run valuation
what's your churn cacked burn are poo
growth rate and this would create very
dramatic cinematic events on the podcast
and this entertainment value is actually
what drove more listeners there's a lot
of very smart people when you listen to
them to them talk they're not
entertaining so they can't hold an
audience but if you can if you can earn
the right to educate by entertaining
first you take off and so I started just
doing this same format over and over and
eventually when I had about 500 episodes
published people were messaging me or
putting on iTunes Nathan you have so
many shows recorded where do I start and
I said oh my gosh I got to make these
searchable somehow and that's when we
basically came off the spectrograph
which converts the audio file it's about
a thousand images and it will know when
the CEO says we passed you know 100
million in revenue it knows the CEO said
100 million it puts that as a data point
on get laka calm my SAS database and if
you click that data point in the
database on the website it will play the
voice segment where that that data point
came from so so that's how that all
coalesced from podcast a database got it
and then you take that database and you
basically solve subscription
model to anyone who wants to get access
to all of these what really is hard to
find metrics or granular metrics for
these businesses that's that's exactly
right and this is like by the way not a
popular thing you know that we have a
lot of CEOs who come on or their PR firm
reaches out because we have a show doing
very well they'll say we'd love to have
our guest on but they don't the CEO is
not prepared and so I hit them hard and
they're like oh my gosh PR team don't
let Nathan publish that I shared way too
much but I'll publish it like seven
times it was so good all right and and
so this is make them happy and then they
end up complaining the press and the
press writes really nasty things about
what I'm doing but ultimately I think
the software environment overall
appreciates that I've got a database of
1,500 companies that are all private
that share their data a lot of people
you know zoom I had Eric one on with
zoom 18 months prior to IPO the date I
got from him was was not published the
you know economics of zoom was not
published anywhere else so our traffic
went like right ones there were rumors
about the zoom potentially filing rs1
the traffic on the doing were you shot
through the roof because it's really the
only source founders had direct from
Eric with you know economic data and so
you know that's kind of why I kept doing
it and how I kept building the show got
it and what are you doing they complain
right look I've had people come on and
literally call me up and say hey can you
edit this out yeah they're freaking out
except how do you handle that when I
record with somebody and they know it's
public and then they email me and moan
about it
I just sense total weakness I think come
on like yeah you didn't sound perfect
but like it was a moment when you
weren't scripted and it was the truth
and like no I'm not gonna edit it out
the excuse I this is make people happy
by the way look a lot of people do
podcast because they want to make
friends with the person they're
interviewing I generally don't do that
in some cases yes but generally my
responsibilities to the audience not the
guests and so I don't edit these and the
excuse I'll use is you know I'm
basically a one-man shop with 30
contractors I'll just say you know you
know my publishing team will evaluate
editing the episode but it's unlikely
they will they never give guests control
over if the final version and so so I've
never added an episode I've published
all of them we have a lot of cease and
desists but they don't go anywhere
because again every founder signs the
waiver that says we own the rights the
audio before they schedule yeah and I
guess part of this too is as you as you
think about this like are there elements
that you can use the data for whether
it's investing or other applications
than just putting in a database and
selling a subscription to it or is it
really just hey we've come up with a
very kind of clever unique way to take
that audio put it into a database and
the best way to monetize that is by some
of those subscriptions so that was the
first piece but what I started realizing
is a lot of these founders would then
rely on me for benchmarking data which
then they said Nathan can you help me
with my board deck can you help me raise
can you help me sell and so I helped
these companies you know I would you
know hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of deals right whether it's
raising selling whatever or buying other
companies over like between 2016 and
2018 and 2018 I said you know what I
should start doing some of these deals
myself so I started writing checks into
the C funds as an LP and watching how
the VC funds analyze these companies to
learn and I realize well I think the
real opportunity here is actually to
create an a new asset class and what I
mean by that is you know software today
you know Salesforce really brought it in
I would say twenty two thousand seven
eight ish but there's now a standard set
of metrics that every software company
private or public should be tracking
right you know obviously mor growth AR
growth kak churn ARPU net expansion
network there's probably 20 key metrics
and if you have all those metrics for a
large amount of companies you can start
generating a credit score for SAS
companies and you can in loan against
the credit score or if I don't do the
loan directly I can sell the credit
score to a bank or to the C firm who's
running diligence on the company with
the founders permission and so this
credit score is you asked is it just a
clever way to create the podcast to
create a
the answer is at first yes sure to make
money but now what I'm doing is I'm
using this massive data set we're
tracking about twenty billion dollars in
real time revenue from private b2b SAS
companies via their plaid connection to
our tech stack so we have direct access
to their bank accounts we generate a
credit score and then we help them raise
capital really really cheap based off
the strength of their credit score and
that's a lot of them are growing and
keeping more of their companies via the
old route which was again raised VC hope
you own 5% when you go public yeah and
there's obviously a number of companies
that are starting to do this and I think
that it's incredibly clever because of
you know your point about no I want a
new asset class but also to the ability
to get the data right there was always
data there for a lot of these companies
now you can actually get it through a
technological solution what do you think
the risk is or if you looked at this and
how to play kind of devil's advocate
with yourself what is the thing that
you're like hey here's where we could
mess this up where here's where it could
actually be a negative thing that to
kind of counter all of those positive
aspects of you try and study history
right so you study Milken and junk bonds
you studied general just debt and how
debt is using government's and you just
you just try and study debt historically
and so the critical things with any debt
is you have to establish what your loss
ratio is gonna be which is a bit of a
trick question when you're raising
capital because if someone asks you with
your loss ratio and you say we haven't
had any losses they're gonna say well
your sample size isn't big enough
you should have losses and if you say
you have a 1 to 2% loss rate which is
you know generally healthy for people
with large you know loan tape debt books
they're gonna say oh well you have one
or two percent losses it's not good so
you can't win answering that question
it's a bad question that being said what
I'm trying to do is build a structure
where I can deploy capital indice ask um
'pn ease you know less than 60 seconds
after they connect their bank account
with our tech stack because I can run
the credit score very quick so I don't
need an underwriting team I don't need a
fancy office space it's just a credit
score and when you add up all the
private software companies in the world
today there's a lot of different
estimations on what that total value
might be worth but you can just look at
the public SAS market look at the best
more venture index I mean this is gonna
be a multi trillion that trillions in
trillions of dollars here over the next
10 to 20 years a software continues to
eat the world I want to be the guy that
has the best data on software business
risk which will make me than that
hopefully the top source for debt into
that space and so I want to build you
know 100 200 billion dollar debt
portfolio into software companies over
the next call it you know decade two
decades and do you ever have any
aspirations to go outside of the SAS
companies whether it's into e-commerce
or other types of subscription
businesses or do you really feel like
that SAS niche is big enough and also
kind of the sweet spot for you the
question I spend a lot of time asked
myself is what is my unique advantage
like what is the the moat that I've
built the distribution moat that I
currently have built is totally focused
on software the magazine the database
the podcast it's all software it's not
the e-commerce show it's not the
e-commerce magnet's software that's
right hub there's a massive advantage so
for the foreseeable future I'm gonna
hyper focus on software and by the way
there are so many great products for
like e-commerce brands whether it's
PayPal cash stripe is now doing advances
on your daily revenue their comings like
clear bank that have raised a lot of
money that are doing you know two month
four month terms on your facebook ad
spend via you know Shopify just launched
Shopify money you saw our friend Danko
just joined Shopify full-time to help
build that so by the way everyone's
gonna get into this space you're just
like AWS is gonna start you know doing
more loans against AWS spend this is
gonna be a very popular thing what I'm
gonna try and do is loan money where to
software companies where there are no
restrictions on how they spend it you
can spend it on people you can spend on
your Facebook Aspen or you can spend it
on your AWS spend but my goal is because
I have the largest data set is that I
can best price the software companies
risk of default and because of my best
pricing algo I can give them the
cheapest price and in this space in my
opinion pump because I'm not like a VC
selling my network value if you take my
money it's really just who can give you
the cheapest capital so I think this is
a beautiful like thing to leverage for
me which is if capital is actually how
you scale like that is the network of
as long as you have the asset of the
data you can win and I do think debt
into software it's going to be a
zero-sum game there will be one winner
because whoever builds the most loan
tape the fastest can get back leveraged
collateralized secure dies the loans
drive their costs down and pass the
savings on to founders what do you think
when we get to that commoditize level
like what does the price of capital
become zero
like is there some point where it
actually just goes to zero cost of
capital well this is a little bit I mean
why I've enjoyed our conversations and
and I'm trying interview more people
with traditional banking and find like
FinTech backgrounds I don't yet know the
direct correlation behind fiscal policy
let's just in say in the United States
and cost of software debt like all I
know is that what the zero percent
interest rate money is being pumped in
the system what like crazy right water
flows of it so what does that mean for
software debt well what did slack do
about three weeks ago right they raised
I forget six hundred million seven
hundred million or something at like I
wanna see was like point five percent
interest rate which they could choose to
pay back or issue stock because the cost
of capital so cheap so I just think the
theory that I currently have and I can
be convinced of many different angles
here my current theory is if you
continue to see federal balance sheets
of governments across the world growing
because money is being printed like
crazy it's going to drastically undercut
VC's ability to get meaningful chunks of
salt private software companies because
debt is gonna be so cheap like that's my
current thesis so I'm keeping my pulse
on getting more cheap capital what that
means is I will take my current loan
tape refinance it with a bank cell
though based not so I still hold the
paper but sell the loans to a bank as
collateral and my cost capital goes from
ten percent I did this the other day
from 10 percent down a three and a half
percent which means I can now loan
profitably to bootstrap software
companies and a four percent interest
rate s VB doesn't even do that sort of
rate with an institutionally backed
software company there's stuff like for
fiber plus like two or three so again
answer question I don't know the
correlation between like
federal fiscal policy and software debt
but I know there is some correlation and
that's what I'm trying to study right
now yeah it's super interesting I don't
think anyone knows the exact answer
right yeah we kind of generally know
what what should happen but uh just like
we're seeing the stock market explode
when the economic data is going bad it
snows it makes no sense to me know
what's your take on it why do you think
is happening well so look thankfully I'm
a guy where like I don't have to have I
don't have to give much thought to what
other people think of me so I'll just
say exact like it is this is this is
never waste a good crisis I guarantee
you
Trump's cabinet when this thing start
breaking out January February is
thinking chaos is very good right Trump
created chaos in the 2016 election
divide and conquer and it worked
chaos can only be good now they can't
come out and say we love a virus that
kills hundreds of thousands of people
who's gonna help get Trump reelected
right so that's obviously a
controversial thing to say but what's
happening I mean look at what's
happening right Trump's cabinet
generally is very very wealthy when you
print money right it drives obviously
will eventually drive inflation the
winners of inflation and you preach this
are asset holders asset prices go up the
losers are those in cash I mean we just
saw Buffett yesterday right what did he
do like the airline's are getting a
bailout a lot of people are saying well
you should buy equities right now based
off what you think Trump's gonna bail
out because their equities will pump
what did buffa do he sold all the
airlines which just agreed to a massive
bailout like what the heck's going on
here we'll remember when money's being
printed right cash is the loser
and nobody has more cash than Buffett so
he's looking at the airline's now
potentially in thinking these CEOs are
now gonna act irrationally because they
know they can ever fail they will always
get bailed out well the risk reward
structure definitely changed for the
incentives change on top of that the big
takeaway I had from the Berkshire
meeting was he was saying all of the
things that would make you think he is
bullish
you know never bet against America and
all this guy stuff but there was two key
points one was he didn't
in March when asset prices you know the
public markets went down 30%
so he didn't deploy capital but then
also to was he sold the airlines right
so he was actually shedding assets
rather than acquiring them and what that
told me was he probably thinks it's
gonna get worse before it gets better I
don't know if you took away the same
thing I I don't study it as closely as
you do or alright so I would I would
kind of my way of figuring out that
answer would be to interview a lot of
people like you but I mean look
generally speaking right now I feel a
bit upset that so much money is being
printed because I worked my butt off to
save money over the past decade like I
worked my butt off to spend less than I
made to save money and now with what's
the federal balance shift like like just
money printed six-and-a-half total
balance shifts like 21 22 or something
at this point over 104 percent of GDP
like it makes me a little upset because
it means every dollar I held essentially
you could argue because the balance
sheet double is worth 1/2 so every
dollar I worked my butt off to save is
now worth 50 cents and in what's
frustrating is money being printed
doesn't necessarily benefit people like
me that have saved money that own no
assets like so the person listening
right now with no assets but you worked
really hard to save three thousand
dollars over the past decade great now
that three grand is worth way less
because prices will increase and so like
you know you had you did a great
interview at Jeff booth and and you know
I interviewed him as well and like one
of the things that I you know I learned
from him is impressed and piss off so
articulately this is you essentially
right now have capitalism like happening
at the top at the bottom which are let
the small businesses fail if they go out
of business go out of business
oh but here's like a PPP safety net
which will save some maybe maybe right
but it runs out like a week then at the
top you have like these corporate
bailouts so it's like socialism up the
top and capitals on at the bottom which
is just it's backwards so I mean Andrew
I spend a lot of my ear sorry pump I
spend a lot of my time talking to people
like you pressed it like just anyone to
try and understand when this thing
actually breaks when when when does this
break and are the current government
officials like if I'm Trump I'm actually
trying I'm trying to drive a bigger
wedge between the haves and have-nots to
create chaos because that's what's gonna
get me reelected so that's what drives
me crazy about all this is they're
actually in my opinion is very little
incentive for governments to not print
more money of course it's a it's a piggy
bank why would you not print more if
there's more access excuse a good answer
to this I mean look it's just incentives
right like if they can print more they
will print more this gives them an
excuse to do it there's a nuance here
which is if you want to stop the
short-term pain is actually the right
decision
right it's this weird thing we're like
long-term it's really bad but short-term
like the reason why the stock market has
recovered is most likely because the
central bank actions right so like
they've done a good job of stabilizing
and then driving some recovery the
question is is it sustainable right or
will we see just another correction here
in the coming weeks and then to is what
is the right trade-off between the
short-term pain versus the long-term
benefit and vice versa I think a lot of
people who are complaining about the Fed
actions are saying look long-term this
is bad but we should always optimize for
the long term rather than the short-term
obviously the people who think they've
done a pretty good job are the people
who who want to optimize for the short
term so we'll see there one of things I
saw you tweet though that was really why
was this idea of it there's a lot of
people who just got laid off right
there's 30 million Americans that have
filed for new unemployment claims the
last six weeks give or take and now
those people are sitting there saying
like what am I gonna do
and you tweet it was basically this idea
of like hey that side house so you
wanted to go do like go after it right
go go acquire a new skill like kind of
take action maybe talk a little bit
about how you're thinking about that
right now and if you were one of those
people who had just gotten laid off what
would you actually do on a tactical
basis in order to kind of move in that
direction yeah so when I say like go do
like that side hustle thing what I mean
is is you come into like a core belief I
have which is right now developers if I
asked you to develop like a code or a
developer at Microsoft get paid more or
less than an artist and in Brooklyn
warehouse what would your answer be
developer developer right everyone's
gonna say developers that you hear
constantly headlines we
Prue's enough stem engineers Apple wants
to hire people Facebook wants to hire
people that can't find them in the
States so developers are seeing just
ridiculous salaries the thing is when
you look at AI and what can be coated
right it's actually pretty easy to code
like coding is just a your writing rules
it's actually very easy to automate rule
writing what's really really hard to
automate is creativity and empathy being
the emotional side you hear about these
robotics companies the hardest thing we
have so like replicate is not like the
physical movement of the elbow of on the
robot because that's easy it's making
the robot cry when the human it's
talking to says something sad and so
like I fundamentally believe that a
decade from now creatives will make be
making more than developers and so with
that kind of Lego block of truth right I
try and think about like what's not
gonna change right over the next decade
so I think that it that is going to be a
truth ten years from now and with that
truth what I'm trying to our ticket
people is like go into that creative
thing that you thought give a unique
ability to do and start building the
distribution channels around that thing
there are so many tools like sub stack
patreon like II that make this stuff so
easy to get going and monetize there's
no Etsy shop there's no reason not to
get going on it especially with free
time now this this comment is not meant
to say like you should try and when
we're all on lockdown trying to survive
and we have family members sick it's not
to say you should try and like be
productive at all hours of the day but
you do probably now have some free time
when you're not in the office and you
should double down on building some of
these channels my version of that is I'm
doubling down on channels that used to
cost me a lot of money to secure that I
can now get really cheap because no one
else is spending money in those channels
you know it makes a ton of sense
incomplete arbitrage one of the one of
the things that is kind of a hot topic
among people especially creating content
looking to monetize those businesses is
the idea of a subscription service for
podcast you have to have a very popular
podcast have you thought about creating
a subscription or kind of a paid podcast
and what's kind of the pros and cons in
your eyes of leaving it free and get as
many people to
as possible versus actually putting it
behind some sort of pay wall and driving
that subscription revenue this is a
really good question and again I think
you have to look at what's been done all
right it's okay let's look at podcast
one right so that's that's one model
which is like get the talent signed get
a rev share agreement and then podcast
one will cross-promote you but also
drive you add revenue you then have
company like advertised cast and that
are just pure ad base they'll say hey
podcaster give us some inventory we'll
fill it with ads to monetize you then
have this other approach which is like
let's build sort of like this network
right so like block works group is a
good example now it's still kind of like
well what is it's gonna be over the long
term but generally it's a group of
people that are talking about business
finance crypto they are you know they
have they create good content they have
nice followings like let's put them all
together and sell ads into them the
question of the question of could you do
a Netflix model which is don't sell ads
just make the content premium and sell
it at like 8 bucks a month it's the same
issue Spotify has which is like what do
you pay Taylor Swift out of the 10
million people paying you for bucks a
month if her audio tracks get downloaded
three percent of the time across all
total downloads that month like you have
to start splitting up that one
subscription fee amongst all the talent
under your umbrella and I just think pop
I think that equation is a much harder
equation than just selling ad inventory
have you seen someone you feel like he's
doing this they're like the right way or
is doing the best job than Netflix for
podcasts so I'm less interested in maybe
the Netflix for podcast I think actually
it's more of the way that it could
possibly work is at the individual level
so like rather than you go join a
platform that's selling a bunch of
subscriptions and they've put a bunch of
podcast behind one single pay wall it's
just your podcast specifically and you
go to your fans and say hey I normally
released you know five to seven a week
now I'm going to release three free and
I'm going to put two to four of them
behind the paywall pay you know five or
ten bucks a month and you'll get kind of
these exclusive either episodes or AMAs
you're kind of after the
show type content to me like that would
probably work I agree with you that I'm
not so much sold on like let me buy a
subscription to a platform and then I
get access to all of this context I
don't think the unit economics makes
sense and also to the consumers aren't
yet conditioned to pay for podcasts in
general they may pay for a one-off like
you and I probably would could pick five
podcasts then if they won't behind a
paywall
I'd pay for right but I'm not gonna go
buy like another Spotify type you know
product just for podcast yeah so to your
point about like five oh it's the reason
right now Showtime is probably seeing a
massive increase in subscribers because
billions just came out like I don't
really care about any other Showtime
shows but I love billions right Netflix
when house of cards is popular I would
literally relaunch my Netflix
subscription watch all the house and
then cancel it because of the one
episode so like to your point yes but
you talk about consumer conditioning the
problem I think with podcasts at least
for me right now is consuming the
consumer consumption of audio is still
too dependent on hardware and so what I
mean by that is it's a lot of energy and
effort to get your your iTunes audience
who is used to like their phone and air
pods right the phone air pods to get
them to go on to like a patreon or sub
stack in the web browser to listen to a
gated episode so you know I tried this
with patreon and I got up to like I
think it was a couple hundred people
paying between five and thirty dollars a
month for one gated episode per week and
and here's what happened I'm just like
what happened I lost the motivation to
keep putting up a gated episode every
week because a lot of people were paying
but I could see the listens that's very
few actually consuming the content they
were paying for so it felt weird like in
theory it worked but until there's an
easier way to tip a wall like in iTunes
on the phone certain episodes I just
don't think you're gonna see this model
take off yeah and you see this in the
media right like New York Times Business
Insider a lot of them have realized like
the best way to dry subscriptions
it's just RAM people into the hard
paywall right so literally you just Ram
it in it's like damn I really want to
read this one
fine I'll pay you your $1
yeah whatever it is right but like just
ramming people into that pay wall and
having the content right beyond the pay
wall has been kind of the largest driver
subscriptions for I understand yeah
absolutely the flip side of this is if
you have consumers that are conditioned
to reading blog posts and a browser or
written content it makes sense why sub
stack makes sense right like this is
what they're programmed to do your inner
browser it's not audio it's written and
this is why you're seeing so many people
just scale their sub stock accounts so
aggressively I think that that model
works really really well you just what I
wonder about is four or five years from
now are we as consumers basically gonna
have like 50 different $10 month things
we pay for from the creators that we
love or there are different model that
emerges yeah I mean look it goes so the
whole whole idea of you know are there
gonna be bundles or they're not gonna be
bundles well I just subscribe if you
talk to sub stacked to those guys like
what they would say is I'm just gonna
subscribe to Nathan right and Nathan's
gonna charge me five or ten bucks a
month and I get everything he creates
whether it's written it's audio its
video it's a physical product you know
anything that he does I pay my 10 bucks
a month and I get everything from him
and so maybe I end up you know
subscribing to five people and those are
really the five people I care about the
most they may be in different industries
where they'd all be in one industry but
I'm subscribing to the individual and
not the organization I think we already
see that the question is will that trend
continue and how big can it get when
you're asking somebody to pay for the
subscription rather than just half
follow you on twitter I follow your
email list things like that I think you
nailed it right what I think a lot about
the reason I have built distribution
channels is not to sell the content per
se it is to secure eyeballs of people
who love me where when I launch a new
product it takes off you know I can
basically drop a new book tomorrow and
have it hit a bestseller list like what
is that good or bad leverage I could
launch a under million dollar fund
tomorrow and play that money pretty darn
quickly because I have the deal flow cuz
I have all the founder relationships
already because of the
gasps so I think it's as balance of like
if you clip a paywall how many less
people see it relative to what that
larger audience could do for you in the
future with new products you create and
I think that's the balance for sure
what uh what are you excited about
moving forward like what in your world
are you saying
you mentioned the airports and kind of
going and securing those distribution
channels what else are you either
working on or you're kind of saying look
this is kind of step two and three for
me later this year so I mean one things
I'm trying to do a better job at is look
I'm not on
tik-tok I can't dance but you can learn
from these people look at like this way
I mean and this is gonna be like great
but like you look like this way house in
LA okay it's basically like six of the
top tick talkers one of their parents
I'm sure maybe they did basically rent
to the house in LA they all live in the
same house together and they're just
constantly creating content together
tagging each other and they all grow
each other's followings this is like the
version this is like the like the
business version of this would be like a
block works kind of concept or podcast
one kind of concept but when you look at
like how they do cross promotion which
is what it is like technically define
cross from the way they do is just so
organic and so real I haven't seen a
business case of that like execute to
that degree of simplicity and just ease
and kind of the non adverb you know
serie like where there's no
advertisements approach like I'm trying
to get better actually doing that in in
a business sense where it's not you know
tick-tock videos but instead business
and I think there's a lot of opportunity
for that like for example you know if I
experimented last year I rented for a
weekend just to this big beautiful
mansion in LA and said let me just
experiment with taking a picture of the
mansion to lure people in and email all
the other top podcasters in my space
and we all came for two days and it was
amazing I had a little chef come in and
make make meals but that one thing did
more for the podcast then like 30 other
tactics I tried combined so I'm most
excited about trying to figure out how
to do cross collaborations with people
in a non organic way that is also very
entertaining which means you have to
your enemies in as well there has to be
conflict then this is what a lot of
people join there has to be a lot of
conflict I think the one thing that I've
noticed and I think you've really nailed
this is the media has to be unbiased the
media has to go after facts the media
has a very specific kind of role in
society and most of them are held to
that standard what I think the
podcasters the bloggers email
newsletters tweeters and all that kind
of stuff what they have realized is it's
not about unbiased journalism in that
world that world is all about the
entertainment right and I always joke
with the let's play down I'm like we're
entertaining like that is literally what
we're doing and she's like you guys
aren't like musicians you're not
whatever I say no but we are actually
competing with those people because you
have your air pods in for two hours
today are you gonna listen to music are
you gonna listen to a podcast are you
gonna listen to something else right
like there's competition in rich
greenfield came on one time it and he
said what most people confuse is like
the streaming wars they think it's just
the streaming platforms competing with
each other
heõs no they're part of a bigger picture
which is it's a war of attention who can
hold the consumers attention and it
doesn't actually matter is it on YouTube
is it on
tik-tok is it on Twitter is it on a
podcast like there's only so many hours
in a day and what you understand that
entertainment actually may be a better
way to do it than kind of traditional
news I think that's where you're seeing
a lot of people find success this is
goes back to my point early about
creatives ruling in the future
Entertainment is very hard to codify it
is storytelling
it is like look in the cheap easy one is
look at maybe it's not cheap and easy
and me this is unfair to the Kardashians
but like post nude selfie right is
something that someone's gonna talk
about it like a tick-tock star it's like
who broke up with who like us is like
businesspeople that wouldn't get into
that world we will like discredit a lot
of that but like I think the better
question is like understand why eyeball
stay attracted to that and what is the
analogy of that in a business world and
the most successful
like business use case of that frankly
you're seeing Trump do this there is
always an argument there is always a
conflict at these daily briefings of
corn it's the doctor verse the
businesspeople always like we watch
football because it's the Cowboys
against the Redskins what a lot of
content creators and I'm trying you
better this don't understand is the
closer you can mimic a football game
where there are clearly two sides and in
your ability to keep the attention of
the viewer is predicated on your ability
to force the listener to pick a side
who's your team and the second you're
always gonna tune in absolutely and it
also is it's this weird thing where it
would been a hard to do that without
lots of equipment and other stuff we're
recording this we both probably have $23
microphones right on we're using zoom in
kitchens on our background yeah exactly
right and what ends up happening is yeah
sure could it be better
of course but at the same time
ultimately the content rules right and
as people understand that that the best
content finds an audience really that's
all that matters right and like look at
the advantage we have over national
television or something else because
actually we will have episodes they get
more distribution than some of those TV
shows yep I mean that's exactly right I
mean and to your point like part of that
is a the nature of how the episode is
delivered and then it's it's it's
asynchronous people can consume whenever
they want versus only at 8 p.m. on
Friday but the other part I think is we
have a real opportunity in the business
work from an entertainment perspective
to educate the masses but you can't
again you can't be smart and educate
without entertaining first like if I was
gonna go down a list of things to learn
it's you go read a bunch of books from
playwrights on how they creates
characters like you develop a character
you build to a climax and those are
resolutions study that stuff first to
understand how to create entertainment
and then build in the education on the
flip side and so
that's what I'm spending a lot of my
time thinking right now and by the way
like this it's what's gonna win
elections it's it's all the power in the
next many many decades is gonna come
down to who is the best in my opinion
entertainer and after you entertain what
are you selling the audience and and
who's gonna buy the most of it and
that's who's gonna win who is the most
unlikely person that you believe has a
good chance of becoming president in the
future who's the person that everyone
else would be shocked by your answer but
you actually think they've got a good
chance of running and winning the most
shocking answer I've sent to actually a
lot of time thinking about would be a
vodka Trump as a Democrat as a Democrat
okay explain if I'm Trump okay he's
gonna get reelected he's doing a great
job at creating another enemy in China
the virus is an enemy the Democrats are
an enemy he understands this kind of
polarization I think he wins easily in
2020 now in 2024 what's gonna happen if
you think and go okay is he like we have
this rule and you can only have two
terms and you're supposed to leave but
like Trump isn't really follow rules so
like does he leave or does he not leave
and you looked at me know he's gonna use
the FDR case study where there is you
know 12 years there if you're Trump the
way you win this you have to remember
like Jared and Ivanka are very tight in
like democratic circles in New York you
know Trump argued why he ran as a
Republican and whatever argue that but
my point is I'm Trump you always want to
be setting up board games that you can't
lose games that you can't lose but
people think you can it's right so
people watch to see if you win or not
you always end up winning the way you
always win in 2024 if you're Trump is
you figure out a way to do what you did
to the Republican Party with Ivanka to
the Democratic Party and so you
essentially end up with a ticket of
Donald Trump in a very controversial
third year breaking the law rewriting
the rules with this court appointed
judge you know versus Ivanka Trump on
the Democratic side no matter what
happens with the electorate you
essentially can't lose it's a
still in office so my answer to your
question may be a bonk it doesn't
surprise people but they would think I'd
probably say she would follow her father
on the Republican side
I think it's Ivanka as a Democrat so
it's super interesting because I was
just talking to somebody about you know
I actually think a female would do a
fantastic job as a US president for a
whole bunch of reasons but we were
thinking through like who is that person
right and what I said was I don't think
it's gonna be somebody over the age of
50 like I think the days of like super
old politicians is gonna go to the
wayside and so he's okay well who could
even possibly run and somebody
throughout you know it's a megyn kelly
type but not her right where you've got
kind of this balance between I take no
[ __ ] but I'm also somewhat feminine and
kind of all of these different aspects
around I'm intelligent I'm thoughtful
I'm well-connected etc and so we
ultimately all settled on like yeah
actually a vodka Trump is probably one
of those people that's in the kind of
top five I don't think a single person
would have guessed as a Democrat though
like to your point yeah mine has
historically been the rock right because
I I imagine the rock and Donald Trump
standing on a stage debating each other
and Trump doing exactly what you're
talking about creating conflict and busy
talking [ __ ] right yeah and the rock
just being like hi and reaching his hand
over and put it on his shoulder and be
like shut your candy-ass like he's
charismatic enough we know that physical
stature matters a lot right so he's
taller and just like somebody like that
who is so well recognized around the
world we now are entering a space where
like I don't think historically you
could have done this but I'm waiting for
somebody to actually say I'm gonna be
the president but not because I'm the
smartest person because I'm the best
leader who's gonna build the best team
and so by the way when you elect me or
you vote for me you're voting for here's
my entire team on bringing with me right
and it's almost like going into it
saying like you're not voting on me to
make these decisions because I know I'm
not the best person to make the
decisions here is everyone I'm gonna
bring and you're voting us all together
it's all of us are none of us and I
think that that message like of the
the authenticity of like I'm not the
smartest person when it comes to
geopolitics or healthcare or whatever
like I have the smartest person though
on my team just is a message we haven't
heard before and is one that is likely
to have a good chance of winning in the
future so to your megyn kelly comment I
think a Kim Kardashian becomes president
before megyn kelly does right which is
more in line with like your rock
prediction like when I think of like the
qualifications for president now it has
a different meaning for everyone now
after what's happened with Trump it
really comes down to who has audience
and name recognition first and
intelligence second like I could see
some that fits the persona you just
described like an Andrew yang like hey
I'm really good with you B I'm really
but I'm really bad on you know how do we
be al Qaeda right so so I'm gonna have a
great line you're gonna vote us all in
my VP but I just think even like an
Andrew yang gets killed by somebody that
understands how to communicate more
effectively than him and the form of
entertainment so again you want the
presidency to be the smartest best
leader I just think people now think of
the presidency kind of like how you
would submit a casting tape to go on Big
Brother
it's how controls were going to be in
two minutes
submit your casting video hope the
American people love it and then boom
now your president
I told story before the podcast but one
of the most eye-opening things that I've
consumed over the last year is when
Bernie Sanders went on Joe Rogan so you
know admittedly I agree with very little
with Bernie Sanders and kind of his
whole position but I had exactly the
kind of thought of him that the media
wants you to have right which is like
he's kind of crazy he's really out there
he's super extreme like all of these
things and when he sat down with Joe
Rogan I listened to it more so just to
try to understand like how does he come
to these conclusions and he was very
very thoughtful he had explanations for
why he was doing what he was doing he
had data to back up his claims like all
these things which you didn't get from
the mainstream media
and it clicked for me like they want the
salacious headline they want the
extremes right they need that conflict
they need all that to drive the eyeballs
but if you put them in a different
setting where it's not all about what's
the two-minute clip and you say hey
we're gonna sit down and talk for two to
three hours and you're gonna explain to
me in detail everything you believe why
you believe it how you're gonna execute
on it your halo this guy's like not an
idiot right doesn't mean I necessarily
switch and agree with everything he says
but it was a very different kind of way
that I thought about him and then I
immediately thought what I bet you every
candidates that way both good and bad
because you just don't see them in that
environment and have the ability to to
kind of show that intelligence because
it is all about as long as CNN and Fox
and these math and Facebook and Google
are driven by ad revenue it will always
be the salacious headline always so we
will continue to have a president in the
United States that is a great
entertainer above the best intelligence
until the incentive structure behind
these media companies changes and
they're not making money off ad revenue
by this is where I think we didn't talk
a ton about this but like this is where
I think the decentralized application
really comes into play if Twitter can
get off a model that is driven by you
know quarterly reports to the stock
market and Jack can really move the
thing off where it says hey every time
someone like pump tweets and contributes
con to the platform you're awarded some
form of token or you know a war utility
value for building the network then
there's no centralized ownership or
profit motive right for the business
it's actually all utility driven my
opinion that is actually what brings the
world back to a rational place where
there is not a profit motive for ad
dollars but rather a utility value for
the the value of the network I couldn't
I couldn't agree more
before we wrap up here what is the most
important book you've ever read other
than your ax man most important okay so
this was one this was one given to me by
gentlemen named Doug Juana Rana who was
my angel investor at hey oh okay I was
in the 90 that was 20 years old
we'd raised five hundred thousand bucks
an angel capital
October 11th we got this acquisition
offer from Ryan Alice at eye contact six
and half million dollar it's actually
fun we got this contact you know from
them and my original thought was this
would be great to sell the business but
like I can't like by the way here's the
letter on page 243 six and a half
million like it's no joke from Ryan Alex
right and I was going this was right
after the board meeting where the board
said anything you can't sell we need
bigger returns and I was just devastated
dug wanna Reina an early angel investor
gave me this book called The Four
Agreements
which maybe you've read but there were
reason I think it's been the most
impactful book for me is it simple it's
easy to read and you find yourself
nodding yes as you read it but like
writing a book where people nod yes is
is smart and it's easy cuz it's a
page-turner but where they adds another
level is it it tells it in a in a way
kind of as a parable where it's a
constant good reminder you know of just
four things you should always do well in
your life and so like that book in that
moment I just remember the sense of good
feeling I had after I read it in that
very stressful moan of my life was
impact when I remember to this day and I
try and read but I haven't read in a
while but I try and reread it once a
year the episode I release today with
Bill Perkins it was one of the two books
that he recommended as well he really
yeah so we're starting I see these
trends and here's the first one to
recommend it now you're the second oh
yeah it's a it's a quits a quick read
it's a quick read people I think people
listening are going okay when pomp puts
out a book what's that what's the title
gonna be that's what everyone wants to
know I have no plans of that what's I
think I'm better in 280 characters that
you you're probably are pretty good at
that all right last question for you
then you get asked me one question and
did aliens believer or non-believer
I feel like if I ever do something very
important in life this 20 second answer
I gave was gonna be replayed back to me
and I want to have it as an out so I'm
gonna say I believe in aliens because
that's like a convenient group of people
that can't fight back if I say that they
cause me some sort of harm and I can use
them as an enemy that has no fighting
chance of winning because they have no
voice so yes I believe in aliens wait a
minute Martin us I want to believe in
aliens money keeps being printed what is
more likely to happen in the next decade
a new Bretton Woods where things are
currencies are debased and everything's
tied back to the dollar it's still the
global reserve currency or there is we
we transition where it is the dollar but
the dollar is backed by bitcoins that of
gold so what's more likely to happen in
Europe and next ten years new Bretton
Woods or a Bitcoin back currency I think
there is a 0% chance or near zero I will
say zero but like less than 1% chance
that you will see a return to the gold
standard or a dollar back buy Bitcoin I
think that those two things are very
very separate at this point and so I'm
going to kind of find the middle ground
a little bit which is I actually think
that there will be some variation a very
watered down version of like a Bretton
Woods but basically some new agreement
around money in the world and multiple
nations are involved that type of thing
at the same time you will see a
continued rise of kind of this
alternative financial system with
Bitcoin being that base unit of account
Jack Dorsey recently did an interview
with the Lex Friedman who's the MIT
professor who is super into machine
learning and artificial intelligence and
in it he describes that look the reason
why I'm so bullish on Bitcoin is because
I believe the internet needs a native
currency and he talks all about like
with square how if they want to roll a
product out on the internet they have to
go jurisdiction by jurisdiction and get
all these approvals and he's like it's
all because there's different currencies
there's different regular
environments all this kind of stuff he
goes the thing is that the Internet is
kind of its own economy right so I
recently wrote a thing where Peters de
Haan came on who's kind of a global
strategist right he talked about
demographics around the world so you're
China's got an aging population the u.s.
average age is lower than China's it's
better than a lot of South American
countries and that's kind of bullish for
America very bearish for China in other
places but the one thing that he didn't
talk about but I fundamentally believe
is if you take the internet or the
digital world and say that is one
economy it has the youngest user base
it's the fastest growing and it's
actually the largest economy right and
so if you can kind of separate the
physical from the digital world all of a
sudden that digital economy if you look
at it from a demographic basis or it's
very very bullish and so in that world
we're currently using the physical
currencies in the Fiat not physical and
my actual physical but physical world
currencies or Fiats in a digital world
doesn't make much sense and so I think
that you'll have that rise but obviously
the the physical world governments and
things like that aren't going to release
that power and so they're gonna kind of
hold on for as long as they can and
you'll have this digital world built up
at the same time and at some point they
actually gonna be the same exact size
and power and then eventually you'll see
kind of Bitcoin or that digital world
surpass it and it's just something they
can't stop I mean it's just they're
playing on a different playing field and
so I think the writing's on the wall the
big question is just how fast does that
happen and what are the ramifications of
dollars to the reserve currency or no I
think the dollar will continue to be the
world reserve currency until a what we
now think of as digital currency so one
of my big things is like every Kirsty's
gonna be digital right it'll be digital
dollar digital euro digital yen digital
Wanek cetera and then you have something
like Bitcoin stable coins whatever the
competition is not going to be digital
versus not it's gonna be at the monetary
policy level I think ultimately
something like Bitcoin wins but I do
believe that until we get a switch to
like a crypto currency the dollar will
remain the global reserve currency
one military power to words such a
deflationary environment the dollar
continues to kind of suck in all of the
value and then three is at the end of
the day like America I don't care what
country you're in everyone wants to sell
to America everyone wants to build their
business in America and like that kind
of American exceptionalism whether
people like it or not has a lot of
advantages to it and so unless there's
like some major conflict that ends up
getting fought I just don't see the the
dollar falling until you see that crypto
currency or kind of a separation of
state money happening makes a lot of
sense there's a there's literally
hundreds of billions of dollars being
bet on all of this right so like the end
of the day what is my opinion really
matter no I think I think asking the
questions is really important like I'm
spending a lot of my time right now
trying to figure out new wells for me to
consume from and so like watching how
you consume cut other people consume
content is something I'm actually trying
to study right now because I want to
expose myself to new ideas like this too
broadly broaden my thinking so I mean
look this is helpful your pot has been
very helpful hopefully this interview is
available for your audience Bob for sure
where are where can we send people if
they want to find out more about you the
book a lot of stuff that you're doing
yeah Twitter's the best place to chat
with me just at Nathan luck if you want
to check out the book it's you can just
go to capitalist book com or Nathan
latke calm but again the best way to
just chat with me directly is that
Nathan black on Twitter awesome and
we'll listen I appreciate you doing this
I think people are gonna love it and WAP
do it again in the future
all right palm thank you